[Música]
a cena é permanentemente bucólica do
sofrimento alegria é aparente síndrome
de uma culpa católica misturada ao
carnaval do outro agente que fazia amor
nos fogos tema veres e disso gerou uma
cultura descendente mas cedeu aos
olhares vise a voz delicada de uma certa
serpente ouvir a palavra de uma mão
conheça agora suas concubinas não pode
crer
então tá bom espere até que suas meninas
dançando nuas os seus shows e seus
filhos irem para as minas de cobre ferro
ouro ou prata guerra como as das
malvinas síria iraque golfo vietnã
tudo isso já sabemos que já aconteceu
mas o que irá acontecer amanhã não dirá
você muito menos viu cada tempo tem o
seu império ea história é do que
prevaleceu o resto ainda é mistério ou a
sombra que remanesceu a luta a voz é a
poesia do agora amanhã é cada um no seu
sistema bater cartão vem de hora
sustentar o próprio dilema mas se eu te
encaro com este tamanho isso não seria
no mínimo um problema
pensa então sujeito estranho que está no
topo desse esquema
qual é a raça desse safado quem é a mãe
do filho da [ __ ] e seu pai
qual o legado saiu vitorioso de qual
luta qual sua bandeira o brasão e fé
porque é divina graça com ele a justa
afinal de contas o que ele é
eu não sei você mas isso me assusta eu
vou a lugares e ouço verdades é isso que
faço para esclarecer a mesma coisa em
várias cidades várias coisas que eu
queria dizer mas de muitas delas foi
chamado culpado coisas que eu tive que
ver pra crer e eu já gastei muito tempo
no meu quarto ainda tenho muito que
escrever não cantei aos negros neste
instante não chamei nenhuma mulher
eu não faço pose de índio de bandido de
traficante também não andei certo a vida
inteira mas não quero ser como quem não
vê e nem acreditar que é besteira e que
não estamos mesmo à mercê de uma
politicagem bater leira de um exército
patrocinado de uma retórica patriarcal
de um fã me reinado por trás do cenário
político global com a fala
eles fazem chover bênçãos num santo por
no matinal tenho falo do ídolo nas mãos
eles servem com sexo oral é cacho que
como todo mundo aqui o grande maioria
das pessoas aqui todo mundo não é quem
está no brasil como a maioria das
pessoas aqui eu nasci numa família de
católicos não praticantes né
a mãe ao nascer uma família de católicos
não praticantes é que seria isso talvez
aquele que pelo artifício da
conveniência da cultura é participa de
um ambiente religioso
pra mim era sair para comer hambúrguer
eu adorava na missa porque o argumento
que eu tinha era vamos comer um
hambúrguer lá depois da missa
e eu lembro que a minha primeira
experiência mesmo talvez de fato
religiosa foi com meu avô para a missa
meu avô eu passava os finais de semana
na casa dos meus avós
meu avô era daqueles que assiste o
programa religioso sabe e ele ia pra
missa e não dormia lá e me arrastava
para a missa né pra feira e pra mim eu
não me se eu achava aquilo muito curioso
é eu vi ali que tinha uma pessoa muito
bem postada e que todo mundo dava
atenção para ela pensava estepes e deus
é deus deus vem aqui falar com as
pessoas em todo lugar é importante
é essa foi minha primeira quebra de
ilusão assim aquela pessoa não era deus
é o padre que estava conversando né as
pessoas como emissário de deus eu não
conhecia ainda que seria essa questão do
emissário de deus
enfim a vida seguindo o curso da vida
seguindo é eu passei a ouvir aquela
questão ali vendo o padre ali e
descobrindo já que ele não era mais deus
eu passei a prestar atenção nos outros
signos né dentro da igreja
eu reparei um painel ali atrás de um
painel atrás do desenho né
aquele desenho era o calvário era a
crucificação de jesus e eu querendo
entender aquilo me lembro eu perguntei
para minha mãe o que era aquilo dali
fica atrás do padre
os anjos tem jesus tal de cruza o céu da
chura cada
eu fiquei assustado com o cel então
olhei pra ele
a primeira crise existencial chover e
ventar e ali eu não quero o céu mais eu
não quero para o céu e realmente eu tive
medo eu realmente senti medo é verdade
eu senti medo naquele dia eu senti medo
naquele momento
mesmo assim ainda pelos rumos do nosso
condicionamento cultural é eu passei a
freqüentar as aulas de catecismo e nas
aulas de catecismo eu me apaixonei e era
motivo suficiente para o catecismo
mas é ali no próximo do meu pai e eu fiz
a primeira comunhão com a garotinha
os 11 anos de idade e depois de ter
feito a primeira comunhão eu fiquei
sabendo que uma coisa que chamava
perseverança e quando a gente estava ali
a perseverança e fizemos a primeira
comunhão permanecido perseverança
eu quis continuar ali porque ela estava
lá né
e foi ela sair da perseverança do vídeo
endereço há de mais que fazer ali né
vou sair vou sair daqui não tem mais o
que perceberá e perceberam qual até hoje
é ea linda
é nisso
passado mais alguns poucos anos né eu
que eu fui me foi aconselhado fazer a
crisma e que a crise era necessário para
o casal falar assim olha você precisa
crismar para casar a mãe precisa crismal
pra casar e eu era eu conheci uma menina
que era aluna da professora de crisma
nessa época já estava lá boqueirão e tal
já estava bastante revoltado com algumas
coisas sim mas eu fui na crisma em umas
duas semanas três semanas até levar um
fora dela sair da crise continuará crivo
né
é nessa época eu estudava numa numa
escola religiosa uma escola de
orientação protestante é que tinha a
disciplina é bastante rígida assim tem
alguns alunos aqui que foram de lá eles
sabem como é que a disciplina da facilpa
da batista é bastante rígida e mas nada
nada comparado ao que a gente aprendeu
dos estudos da história
os estudos da história a gente eu pude
perceber foi a minha paixão e depois eu
tive um alguns breves momentos com a
faculdade de história lá que em três
vezes de três meses de aula e foi preso
mas não foi por causa de religião
é é mentira não fui preso não só sair da
viatura
é ali estudando as aulas de história me
apaixonando pela história e pesquisando
a história eu também disse nutre um
interesse muito grande pela leitura
sempre flexionado por leitura estava
sempre na biblioteca pegando livros e eu
estava lendo simultaneamente três livros
três dedos
a minha professora da escola na época
tinha aqui fazer o curso superior ela
não tinha curso superior e baixar uma
lei do governo que é preciso ter curso
superior e ela estudou com um monte de
esquerdopata né
graças a deus e nos ensinou ali né falou
com a gente ele sobre um cara chamado
karl marx que falava se a religião é o
ópio do povo é opa eu vou nesse cara
fui lá e peguei o manifesto do partido
comunista para ler os 14/15 anos sei lá
e junto com esses livros eu estava lendo
também um livro chamado malleus
maleficarum que era o nome de uma banda
que eu gostava era tema de músicas de
bandas que eu ouvia e descobrir uma
lewis modificaram foi o livro escrito
não durante a idade média no começo da
idade média no final da idade média
já no começo da idade moderna é é por
dois padres um padre tem um tema tão a
questão de de autoria do livro que foi
usado como um manual de caça às bruxas
responsável pela morte o julgamento e
morte de mais de 100 mil pessoas e isso
me deixou chocado porque a maioria
dessas pessoas eram mulheres e eu
estudei praticamente com mulheres no
catecismo na escola foi uma professora
que representou essa visão e eu fui
fazer a primeira comunhão por causa de
outras duas mulheres e eu não acho que
ele não me parecia honesta não me parece
justo era um questionamento muito
pessoal né mas aquilo ainda não me
parecia certo
não me parecia certo
aí eu descobri que era lá e cá eu não
usava nenhum argumento religioso de uma
crença seja ela qual for
para nortear o meu comportamento para
nortear as minhas escolhas
muito pelo contrário nessa época de
confusão e revolta eu usava isso como
manifesta de raiva né eu escrevi sobre
isso nas músicas nas duas primeiras
músicas que escrevi ainda é um tema
recorrente nas coisas que eu faço
acho que puderam reparar por exemplo
declamei aqui e as músicas que escrevi
há pouco tempo a gente chegou a gravar
uma música com uma banda de moda né tá
na internet que se ouve é a música
chamava cicote don letts my lai deus nos
abençoe a minha vida
sabe aquele garotinho metaleiro que vai
pra frente do palco está com raiva da
religião da família na casa dessas de se
ver se essa posição nessa sociedade
tenta jogar para cima da gente com
relação às crenças que nós devemos
adotar
ele ouve isso daí ele fica super
satisfeito mas a música fala do dinheiro
a música fala do sistema financeiro e
daquilo que está escrito nas notas de
dinheiro que nós conhecemos deus seja
louvado podem pegar suas reais obtiveram
algum né
é para pegar seus reais aí vocês vão
testemunhar em sua escrita em suas notas
é isso sempre me deixou esse
questionamento e eu sempre trago esse
questionamento em qualquer ambiente
cultural que eu possa participar dele
seja na música seja na poesia eu
pergunto porquê porque isso quem tem
essa verdade quem é capaz de como os
deuses de outras religiões arquétipos de
outras religiões de penetrar os dois
mundos de encarar frente a frente os
seres transcendentais de saber mesmo a
verdade sobre as coisas e afirmar eu
tenho uma verdade
siga o que eu estou te falando então a
atitude a questão da atitude de se
afirmar como life
um sinal de importância com o próximo
imagino que muitas religiões ensine isso
só que quando você tem um ser um ser
aqui que pode comunicar com ser ali e
receber informações e dizer que ele tem
na verdade essa pessoa fica muito
poderosa e nós vivemos tempos em que nós
podemos perceber isso cada vez mais
evidente mês o argumento religioso elege
líderes derruba líderes separar famílias
então a questão da atitude o que eu
venho dizer aqui eu não quero falar
sobre o estado laico não veio quero
falar sobre essa questão legal que
constitucionalmente nos garantindo
eu quero só deixar essa mensagem não é
que eu faço as minhas músicas nas minhas
poesias de que essa escolha tem que ser
uma escolha antes de tudo pessoal pra
gente se libertar e pra gente não vê
como semelhante só que desfruta da mesma
filosofia que nós para que nós possamos
ver como semelhantes qualquer um que
tenha as mesmas impressões que nós que
têm a mesma chapa que a gente porque a
gente não sabe quem criou o que de onde
a gente veio pra onde a gente vai e
talvez a beleza da vida seja de fato é
afirmar isso com violência com
agressividade
imagino eu que não seja um caminho
saudável né
quem sabe assim a gente consiga
construir uma perspectiva de futuro mais
iluminada mais amorosa mais carinhosa
mais humana e conseguir fazer o o
paraíso é eterno
aqui mesmo jeito que era no estado
original das coisas
[Aplausos]